all right good people of the internet
sorry for the delay right there joining
me today is a professor of marketing at
Concordia University an author and a
behavioral scientist but most
importantly I believe officially right
now the most returning guest to the
ribbon report dr. Getz so kind of you to
have me again to put up with me yet
again all right we do that's just one
more time let's just finish this you
know every couple months it's been 16
months since my last appearance it's
been 16 months I think it was in August
2017 so it's been a while well it's sort
of fitting so this is actually my last
taping of the year we've taped where you
have a couple more shows coming out that
we taped earlier this week because of my
travel schedule but I thought it's kind
of fitting that you're my last show of
2018 because you were the first of the
first you did our first test show at or
a TV in August of 2015 that's right so
over three years ago about three and a
half years ago that feels like a freakin
lifetime look at you now you're like are
you the most famous person in the world
now third most Lady gaga PewDiePie
pewdie pioneer but it does seem like a
lifetime ago and I more than anything
else I want to cover a ton of new ground
today that's what I want to do got a lot
of new ground right here and I know
you're working on all sorts of things
and you you've got a new book coming and
everything else but first I thought
because you also are on patreon and this
happens to be the topic that everyone's
talking about at the moment I want to
just talk a little bit about censorship
and platforming and deep platforming in
the rest of it do you want to lay out
quickly what happened to Sargon or do
you know you go ahead and do it so just
very briefly for people that don't know
Sargon of Akkad who's a popular youtuber
he was one of the first sort of from the
classical liberal space when I was kind
of waking up to what was going on with
with the Left related to free speech and
sort of the SJW hysteria everyone said
you got to talk to Sargon of Akkad I
didn't even know if it was a real person
or who the hell
guy was he was booted off patreon a
couple days ago with no recourse with no
warning because ten months ago in
February on another channel that's right
not his own channel that's from a very
tiny YouTube channel with 4000
subscribers on an audio interview show
with a non English native speaker which
I only mentioned because the this
conversation was a little stilted
because of the language he said the
n-word and he said it not to be racially
pejorative but he said it because he was
sort of using the language of the
alt-right against themselves example
patreon heard him saying this they don't
think about or look into context and
they booed him and this is actually a
pretty big thing in our space I usually
don't like talking this much at the
beginning of a show and now I hand it to
you what do you make of what's going on
with platform and D platform and we are
both on patreon etcetera well I'll just
say that I mean I was heavily hit but my
PI of the big patreon you know my slice
of the pie is very small I had maybe six
hundred patrons and I think I checked
last maybe a day and a half ago
and I had lost more than a hundred out
of 600 that's a lot so that's a lot it's
not a lot of money that I'm making on
this platform but it's still hurts I
really think that it stems from and I
think it might be one of the things that
you had on the list for us to talk about
you know oftentimes people pit these
binaries against one another you're
either a thinking person or a a
multi-person you either you know it's
either rational or emotional I think one
of the things that you're writing I'm
writing about this in the book right
because I want to explain this very
quick trigger of outrage that arises in
many contexts in universities and
companies and when they deep platform
people so I think people use these fast
and frugal heuristics oftentimes these
heuristics work well but on other other
cases where you miss apply an emotional
reaction in a context where it would
require a bit more cognitive effort this
is where you get some of these problems
so can you give me an example first
where when does a heuristic that just is
like the immediate reaction heuristic if
I'm walking down
taking a shortcut to go home and I see
three young men that look quite
suspicious my heart starts racing I
start maybe sweating a bit my blood
pressure goes up so I'm getting a
emotional reaction
that's physiological based precisely
because it makes sense at that moment
for this autonomic reaction to take
place if I'm trying to solve a calculus
problem then calling all of my emotional
system into action might not be the
right thing so the argument is that it's
not that we are either rational or
emotional being it's that you should
trigger forgive the term
yeah you should activate the correct
system at the appropriate time and I
think what happens with a lot of these
social justice warrior types is that
they're very much driven by the
emotional system in the wrong context
and that's where you get the kinds of
situations like what's our sargon yeah
so to live life as a functioning human
you need a little push and pull on that
right you need you need the emotive
stuff and then you need the the
cognitive stuff why do you think this is
happening at these platforms why do you
think they are bowing I mean they're
really just bowing to the mob every time
and the reason I'm so concerned about it
is not only just because of how I feel
about free speech but we're watching I
mean we're just in slow motion watching
those lines
they're coming both ways but mostly it's
coming let's say from the the SJW left
so I'll use this hand it's moving really
fast this way where it's gonna be that
everybody is gonna be on the outs
because if a guy like Sargon who as far
as I can tell it's just an old school in
Berlin you know he's I'm gonna show
twice yeah and he never said anything
that struck me is unreasonable he seems
like a very reasonable fair guy yeah and
look he's a bit of a troll he's a bit
bit of a provocateur all of those things
but the point is that if a guy like Karl
Karl Benjamin that's his real name if he
can't be on a platform then half the
people that we know and maybe that
includes us can't be riding his
platforms so what do you think is
happening at the high levels of that I
mean it's a combination of many things I
think one of the things is that this
this the the I call it or in my Canadian
Senate in 2017 when I went to talk about
the LCC
Steen thank you very much oh I thank you
for remembering I talked about the I'm a
victim therefore I am ethos right it
used to be a I think therefore I am now
is I'm a victim that so it to stay true
to a victimology ethos you have to be
outraged you have to be indignant you
have to sell flagellate at the altar of
progressivism
and and people are cognitive misers in
other words they're cognitively lazy and
now I've got this autonomic system that
where I can draw on my emotional
indignation to navigate through the
world well for the social justice
warrior types it's easy to fall prey to
the hyper activation of the emotional
system right as you said it's not that
we are this or that and I I think I
emailed you yesterday one of the
concepts that I'm developing in my book
is this idea of what I call epistemic
accord I koto mania and if seeing the
world as sort of opposing binaries we
are rational and we are emotional there
are very clear evolutionary reasons why
we've evolved the capacity to think but
also very clear evolutionary reasons why
anger and envy and schadenfreude and
compassion have also evolved so we're
both just triggered the right system at
the right time so do you think part of
it is just that the speed of the
internet the fact that you can be on
Twitter so quickly releasing this stuff
that you can learn more faster now right
you can listen to podcasts in
double-speed and that you can take in so
much information and shoot out so much
information that that maybe is
triggering your word some of the
hyperactive emotional stuff it's done
yeah I'm as opposed to using a more
rational logical although oh you're not
succumbing to that right so so it's
wrong so it is really an interaction
perhaps of the environment that you're
describing but it has to be the right
personality who succumbs to that
hyperactive emotional system you're not
succumbing to it I'm not succumbing to
it and so I'd like for people to develop
if I don't know if it's the right term
or a good term but Mental Hygiene right
in the same way that we develop personal
hygiene I mean stop for a minute think
about it that what's the context under
which sargon you know uttered that
particular world word and now that there
is so much information that suggests
that there was a con
text why can't you reverse it why can't
you set it correctly well it's because
it's very difficult for people to admit
Mia culpa I was wrong and so then they
anchor in their position and nothing's
gonna move them from him it's very bad
business you know it's interesting
because I do find there are times
especially lately I've really been
trying to not that I was ever like
over-the-top hostile to people on
Twitter but I used to you know go in and
attack people more and or not attack
people but usually attack ideas but now
I do find a lot of I write a draft and I
kind of just take a breath and I'm right
now you know what maybe just let this go
because I sense there's a growing
feeling and maybe it's only online I
hope it's only online that people really
want to burn everything down yeah do you
sense that I mean as someone that
studies back yeah you study behavior
that people who live in the West you
know I live in the United States you
would be kind of we live in two of the
freest countries in the history of the
world you can wake up if you live in
America or Canada and basically do
whatever you want it doesn't mean you're
gonna write successful at it or you can
try at least and yet there is this
growing feeling that we gotta just tear
this whole thing down yeah it's it's
unbelievable I mean one of the the
things that people tell me when they
meet me in person is they say well you
know I've seen you brawl with people on
Twitter and yet in the rest of your
interactions you seem to be so lovely
and jovial and friendly well the reality
is that Twitter brings out the worst in
all of us right it i analogize it it's
akin to two guys brawling in an alley
right but they you oftentimes those who
criticize you will commit what's called
the fundamental attribution error the
fundamental attribution error if I may
just the other side it's where you you
missed appear to teach me thank you
you're very kind
you miss attribute something
dispositional e to the person when it
should have been attributed to the
situation right so when I am brawling
usually with a smile on my face with
someone on Twitter it's the situation
that's at hand
that's causing me to be combative that's
not my disposition when i when i tuck my
children to bed and i kissed them i
don't troll them and call them castrato
right but but somehow people attribute
that to you this positionally you're a
combative person then they meet you in
the say my god you're so warm and smiley
and so on
so I think there are all sorts of really
interesting psychological processes that
are causing us to behave in ways on
Twitter that otherwise we wouldn't
behave that would be interesting I don't
know if you know anything about that
specifically but just because of the way
you've studied behavior to know that
when other technologies came out over
the course of human history if they so
quickly changed the way we behave with
each other so say when the printing
press came out and now more people that
information did that immediately mean
that people are yelling at each other
more or something like that I wonder if
there is some I don't know I don't know
about that but I could say do you know
what is the one industry that is always
at the cutting edge of technology yes my
friend it's poor very good look Kix I
saw a book it says you know we're not
gonna do this it's unbelievable guys are
moving to tape I'm gonna do this on film
and right yeah but what's the purpose
there well it's just that they they're
always trying to find the new ways to
deliver that consume Ettore experience
to you and therefore they are at they're
not just creating pornography which is
not very difficult to explain from their
perspective they are really at the at
the front of finding new technologies to
deliver these systems so which speaks to
another point that I was gonna talk
about often times I get emails from
people why did you choose to apply you
know all your you know biological
knowledge your psychological knowledge
to marketing and the answer to that for
me is that marketing and consumer
behavior is the perfect place to study
human nature short of my breathing the
thing that I do most is consume but I
don't just consume coca-cola and
Starbucks I consume friendships we
consume ideas we consume religious
narratives we so everything is consuming
Tory so the reason why I love marketing
so much because people think of the term
marketing in a colloquial sense you're
trying to market the next hip party
right right so they think I sit there
and I design restaurant menus as my job
right well if that was true you probably
had a lot more money
if you add master that what the hell
would you be teaching for exactly
marketing is really so some marketers or
marketing professors are anthropologists
who study the the the ethnography of
consumption others are psychologists who
study the psychological basis of
consumption others are applied
mathematicians so in the same way that a
climatologist uses mathematical models
to study climate systems applied
mathematicians study marketing systems
so people have to understand that
there's a different term that's being
used when you think about marketing as a
colloquial term versus marketing as a
scientific discipline marketing as a
scientific discipline is simply the
application of coordinate disciplines
for the study of the marketing realm
okay so if we want to bring this back
then to the first question sure about
the platforming as a behavioral
scientist perhaps we're not doing
something right as consumers of these
platforms you know it's that we're
really the product but as the users of
these platforms is there a behavioral
modification we should be doing to get
these companies to behave differently
towards us I think as long as there are
no direct consequences to their
behaviors I mean really when when people
boycotts patreon I mean yes there's
sending a message to patreon but the
most immediate effect that is felt is by
you and me right yeah and so I did this
live stream last night and I said and
this is completely true that I've lost
about five hundred some-odd patrons
we've lost about I think it's around
five thousand bucks a month already Wow
but as I'm watching the number drop I'm
honestly truly yet I'm inspired in a way
like it could because it's like oh
people are standing up for themselves so
it's like and yet and a lot of them are
finding me on my website now and doing
it there so it's not like I'm taking a
complete financial hit but people are
messaging me and saying I'm not gonna
take it anymore and for that I'm like so
it's weird I'm like kind of inspired on
one hand and then my business you know
this Dave is like oh [ __ ] but and I have
to agree with you because one of the one
of the sort of the signature things that
I sign off with often times is I tell
people don't sit idly you have a voice
get engaged yeah and so it's difficult
to then get upset at people for getting
engaged simply because you take a
financial hit right
the bigger picture I agree with you I
understand the frustration and I hope
that jack conte is is watching this what
do you make of the behavior of people
that live in free societies that are
afraid to actually be free because you
know I just traveled the world all year
which ordinary and the amount of people
that I met especially in the
Scandinavian countries but all over the
world and including America and we did
probably 15 stops in Canada people that
live in free societies that actually are
afraid to speak it drives me absolutely
crazy
I respect jihadists more than I respect
people in free societies who refuse to
speak because the jihadis at police are
really committed they wake up every
morning and they have a goal it's a goal
that you and I might find it to be
executable but they are committed those
who sit quietly while you know the the
ugly the tsunami of lunacy is coming
upon us I have nothing but disdain for
them and it really isn't so what is that
behaviorally what is that is that just a
function of our excess in the West we've
done it right basically we're basically
free we got PlayStation we are coca-cola
we got Nike and we've been lulled into
nothing I think it's many things number
one I truly believe that those who come
from societies that weren't free ayaan
Hirsi Ali myself we really do understand
what magical reality the West is and the
whole totality of societies that have
ever existed in the the compendium of
societies in the world we're nothing but
a small bleep we've really done
something right I think most Westerners
don't know that there is I mean maybe
sort of at the abstract they know that
there are some really bad places out
there but they take things for granted
they are but Reagan had said I'm going
to paraphrase I remember the exact quote
you know every single generation you
have to be standing you know at the gate
defending freedoms because in every
generations there's going to be
intrusions of some really nefarious
characters trying to take away those
freedoms and so maybe in your book maybe
in mind we have to find ways to come up
with prescript
to get the silent majority to speak yeah
do you know what the secret is to get
them to speak I don't know what the
secret is
other than you've got to keep telling
them that that's the answer like there
because that's the question I probably
get more at any QA that I do than
anything else is I want to get involved
but I don't know what to do and it's
like you don't have to make a youtube
channel tomorrow although I tell people
get on all of these platforms you do
those things but just in your own life
don't be afraid of having these
conversations if you're truly afraid
that you're gonna say I'm for low taxes
and your cousin's gonna tell you you're
a racist that's not gonna magically get
better yeah you know what I mean it's
gonna actually it'll magically get worse
so I think it's just on you person
watching this now do do it earlier today
I was at Balboa Island in Newport Beach
with my family and we ran into an older
gentleman I think he's 80 years old we
had seen him around we're often in
California and we love his dog he's got
a Shetland Shepherd so we stopped to pet
the dog and we ended up talking at one
point you know so I guess he's finding
out what I do and so on and he tells me
with a lot of hesitation as if there's
going to be this great repercussion on
him he admits to me this very very dark
secret he's a trump supporter I said oh
why do you say that with such hesitation
why so here's an 80 year old gentleman
who lives supposedly in the most free
society sitting on a free street in
Newport Beach yet he felt sufficiently
tepid about simply saying that he
supports the current sitting US
president that captures it all that that
that's it I mean to be free and to be
well you're your own hostage you know
the other thing I find very interesting
is that it so I was speaking actually
with Jordan and a few others at an event
this was the event in 2017 where we were
going to speak about the stifling of
free speech on University campuses that
was shut down and then it was
rescheduled yeah so in the Q&A someone
asked who who is of each of the people
who were in the panel who is your sort
of freedom hero
and my answer was well it's all the
people who do what we do but they do it
in the Middle East right where the
repercussions on them is they might be
taken the middle of the night and you'll
never hear from them again
now what upsets me is that if you ask
people in the West as you were saying
earlier they were too afraid to speak
well what are you afraid of it's
unbelievable the banality of their fears
well I'm a so if they're a professor
well I'm afraid that might the chair of
my department might give me my course
load on Tuesdays but he knows that on
Tuesdays my son has soccer practice
that's what you're basing the whole
edifice of your defense of freedom on
the fact that he like screw around with
your teacher so so there is a
misalignment between what people fear I
mean I get a million death threats yeah
that's that's real my god I use I had
last semester by the way in that last
answer in fall 2017 I had to be escorted
on my university with security I had to
file a police report with the Montreal
police I mean that's a lot worse than
you didn't give me the right schedule to
teach on Tuesday because my but that's
the banality of their fears their
unfounded just speak up yeah I always
ask a lot of my more courageous guests
this but what do you think it is about
you do you think it's just because of
what happened to you in Lebanon growing
up I mean if people don't know the story
they absolutely should check out our
other interviews because you're you're
your life story is incredible Joey do
summarize it yeah if you want to do that
I mean we're Lebanese Jews who lived in
Lebanon I mean my parents my siblings
who are much older than me myself were
all born in Lebanon we were part of the
last group of Lebanese Jews who were
still in Lebanon the civil war broke out
into the mid 70s where it was no longer
possible to be Jewish in Lebanon and so
we have to leave you know very very
quickly so it my personal history of
course is part of the reason why I do
what I do but I really think it's the
unique random combination of genes that
makes who Gaza is which is I'm genuinely
and I say this without any hyperbole I'm
genuinely offended by BS so sometimes my
wife will see me
I have my head in my hand I'm oh my god
what did somebody write and it'll be
something that I just read there is a
retreat in Costa Rica where whites are
not allowed yeah this was like the hot
thing that vici was tweeting it exactly
and then I watch it I went absolutely
berserk I said how could it be that the
same society that created Martin Luther
King this is not four thousand years ago
this is within well not maybe you being
alive but I was maybe two three years
old yeah this the the same society that
created Martin Luther King 40 50 years
later is the same society that rejoices
right vice news was not saying look at
these idiots there's how progressive it
is that there is a a American woman who
has started a retreat where whites are
not allowed where they take breaks from
white people well just look at my tone
now it upsets me yeah now possibly
because I also come from the society
where I come from where I know what real
hatred is there is no such hatred in the
u.s. stop pretending that there is such
a thing yeah
well we're looking for it all the time
we're looking if you want to find racism
everywhere and bigotry everywhere guess
what you will find it and if you don't
you'll just make it up so exactly what's
it been like for you so you just
mentioned having to be escorted off
campus so in a couple times that we've
done this obviously your public profile
has grown and you're extremely outspoken
what's it been like just on campus in
general colleagues I'm guessing you
probably get a lot of silent support and
probably not a lot of public support I
mean it's it's the same old story with
everybody that's the that's the either
depressing or at some level inspiring
part of this that maybe there are many
more of us which would commence firing
but the depressing part is it's like
you're just a man yeah you're just one
guy doing what you think is right how
you have about four hours so let me
summarize a few of the things that have
happened over the past year so my
University and I'm not saying this not
to be diplomatic but there are many many
great things about a university they
truly have given me an environment to
flourish they don't get in my way
they've never come and said don't say
this and don't say that but I think my
public profile now is scaring them so I
know for a fact for example that the
media department at my university I used
to be their hero
five seconds they used to call me and I
won the President's Award the president
of the universities award for the guy
who gets the most international media
coverage that was in 2015 well from 2015
to now my profile has grown about
thirteen trillion times so if I won in
2015 you would think that I'm certainly
up there I've completely become
invisible to the University so they
don't actively come and stop me from
saying something but it's as if they
want to hope that I go away and I've
spoken to a few senior administrators
and it kind of relates back to what we
talked about earlier this kind of
emotional mechanism some of them are
upset at the fact that I called someone
schmuck on Twitter so all of you were
never called anybody issue exactly and
I've actually had some other I'll tell
you another quick story
there was a gentleman with whom I was
communicating on Twitter a random person
I have no idea who this person is and at
one point I call them a generate
[ __ ] schmuck okay Twitter banned me
I found out it's because I used the R
word I get a call from a University
Human Resources person after hours to
discuss the fact that a complaint had
been filed against me now I was thinking
oh this must be in the context of my job
as a professor in the university and
there's absolutely no way that they
could anybody could have any reproach
against me because I I conduct myself in
a very very austere you know
professional professorial manner
no no it's they were referring to that
interaction with a random person on
Twitter to which I answer I told the
person who I was speaking to so let me
just make sure that I get the straight
so that when I repeated on high profile
platforms I don't get it wrong you think
that it is within the purview of the
university to contact a professor and
determine what he or she can or can't
say using which tone on Twitter when
they're engaging another person as a
private citizen so if I were to hear you
speaking to your daughter coming out of
the pharmacy in a tone that Ida said
that I didn't approve of can I report
you to the University the conversation
and then very quickly after that so the
fact that the university
are even embolden that they have the
reflex to feel that it is okay for them
to be questioning which word you use on
Twitter is a problem and the fact that
you fought back boldly probably made
them scatter very quick because they
don't expect anyone do the absolute
right so you do you think universities
have a different responsibility when it
comes to speech so of course in the
United States where we have the First
Amendment which is about the government
coming for your speech I think is being
now confused with generally your right
to free speech anyone can say whatever
they want with the various limited
exceptions of fire in a crowded theater
etc etc but you know something like Mark
Lamont Hill a couple weeks ago that that
insanely over the top and and truly
races river to river to the sea passage
should be free from the river sea that
is literally what Hamas says it is a
call for genocide everyone knows what it
is now in my view the school temple and
CNN his network can do whatever they
want they can associate or not associate
but I know there's a little bit of it
and I say that as a as a free speech guy
it's like he can say what he wants you
know the school can associate with who
they want I don't want the government
forcing him to stay or forcing him to go
but that to me is what freedom is it's
the messy exchange of freedom but do you
think in a case like that do you think
universities have an extra
responsibility to protect free speech
when it's speech that they don't agree
with so the way I would answer it all
and although I'm very conflicted about
it I don't think that temple should fine
I say this as a Jewish person yeah who
has a lot of family in Israel I don't
despite the fact that I don't agree with
what he said and he is aping the exact
slogan of Hamas I don't think that they
should fire him I think the only thing
that should make you that should a
fireable offense is that within your
role as a professor in the university if
you do things that violate the dictums
of your job as a professor short of that
I'm a free speech absolutist see that's
the irony of where we're at with the
platform's too because you could also
argue well wait a minute
so our gun did something off platform
and he's getting banned you know they
said they said it's only if you do it on
platform now he did saying off platform
so that's why all of these things are so
confusing and it is intertwined
can I share one other story of not mine
although I want to maybe mention one
other example I'll mention my story
first and then I'll mention another guy
another thing that struck because you're
asking what's happening on your
universities in my in my personal
experience so now the equity and
diversity stuff is spreading like
wildfire across all institutions in
Canada because we have you know Justin
Trudeau who's really pushing this
everywhere right yeah and so they're not
happy well I can't say they but I did
about 15 shows this year in Canada and
they're not the time I mentioned Trudeau
people would boo
do you know how many he was the
punchline of all my jokes and he was
dead at that I had Trudeau and everyone
goes no do you know how many people have
written to me now saying I wish we would
have heeded your warnings about Trudeau
in the past so yes Stan Harper's looking
pretty good these days although I my
prediction regrettably I think he'll win
again but because there isn't anybody
who is who can beat him on the charisma
factor I think the current guy is not
gonna do it I've got you seen Bernie a
coming in oh ok very nice but so so the
equity and diversity stuff the Canadian
government now they endow this thing
called the kind of the research chairs
which is the highest chaired
professorship that the Canadian
government can bestow on a professor now
equity and diversity is a central metric
that is looked at so in the context
where meritocracy should be the defining
ethos of everything right I mean when
you run the hundred meters - there is no
equity in diversity who crosses the line
the furthest right right the size of my
CV and how many people consume the
material in that CV are the metrics no
its equity diversity so I've been a
shared professor I hold it I held a
university-wide chair for 10 years and
again I got this chair in 2008 where my
dossier would have been much much less
than what it is today sure I now applied
for the next chair I lost it the person
to whom I lost it let me just do this is
her CV this is my CV I don't ovulate so
in this case perhaps it had something to
do with the fact that she's a woman so
you're even though you're
a refugee and an immigrant look look
just nice and bronzed if you are brown
and yes round you're from the Middle
East I'm Peter all of those things get
it our own out the window that's right
you don't play that card exactly exactly
when it comes to to those particular
identity politics calculus the one that
matters right now is that one I mean
or if you were indigenous or something
like that being Brown being escaping
decapitation a Lebanon is not as
important as ovulation yeah I think
you're gonna be writing a little bit
about this as well but what do you make
about what's going on right now there
seems to be like a gender war starting
or something and you're saying well just
that there's this weird tension suddenly
between men and women I think that seems
to be bubbling up everywhere that
obviously is somehow connected to this
new version of feminism well I mean
listen I've been I've been dealing with
this even before all the social justice
warriors just the fact that I've been
trying to Darwin eyes the behavioral
sciences in general and consumer
behavior in particular that itself was a
heretical idea so that was thought of a
sexist basically because men and women
like different products men and women
have different look there are many
things that make men and women similar
there are many things that make men and
women different and the only framework
that explains the cataloguing of
similarities and differences is
evolutionary psychology there is no
other game in town right but the fact
that you even recognize that men and
women might have evolved sexual
dimorphism that itself is heretical in
much of the social sciences so even
before the sort of cultural wars that
you hear about just in science itself
you know I'm an interesting guy in terms
of my academic background and that I
really do straddle the Natural Sciences
and the social sciences alright so I
could say the exact same sentence if
it's heard by natural scientists they go
yeah no kidding the exact same sentence
heard by the social scientists booboo
not to give me an example that well just
for example saying that there are
evolved sex differences just that right
I mean the fact that in the 21st century
a professor has to appear in front of
the Canadian Senate to to say the things
that I had to say and then be accused of
being pro genocide what more do I need
to say I mean that that captures the
zeitgeist of lunatic lunacy that exists
what do you think has to happen to turn
this around because on one hand it's
like look all of these conversations
that so many of us are happening there
they're growing you know there's there's
live events happening all over the place
that people are attending and so there
is an awareness of this but I still
sense we're just the frog in the pot
right there's thing is just getting
warmer and warmer and we're looking
around and we're we're realizing oh
there's other frogs in here but they're
looking at us going oh you're getting
warm too it's not to go back to an
earlier point that we talked about we
said how do we get people to get engaged
there's really it's not rocket science
you have to marginalize the voices of
lunacy and you do that by having the
tsunami of Reason overtake the tsunami
of lunacy the problem is that if you
highly committed intellectual terrorists
can hold the rest of the people hostage
right on 9/11 it only took 19 people
it didn't take 19,000 and didn't take 19
million it took 19 people who were very
committed that morning to cause a level
of destruction that is unimaginable by
the same token it doesn't take too many
miscreants and universities to cause
damage but if everybody gets up and says
look I'm indignant about these constant
injuries to truth I won't accept you
saying the things that you're saying
challenge your professor when he or she
says BS challenge your Facebook friend
if you get enough people to marginalize
the voices of lunacy then the very
quickly the tide will will be overturned
do you think that universities let's say
20 years from now are gonna be
completely different I mean the amount
of access to information and to great
minds that you have on YouTube is
incredible I mean you can learn about
psychology from Jordan Peterson you can
learn about behavior from GAD side you
can learn about evolutionary biology
from Brent wise and it's I mean I could
go on sharing on that people are
learning in a new way now and it almost
for as much fun as I had in college and
as much as I learned in college it's
like at some level it's like with this
hysteria if I was a parent why would I
want to pay money to have my kid
reprogrammed it's something that has
nothing to do with any of my beliefs I
think universities will eventually adapt
but it will take much longer than 20
years so and
I say this somewhat facetiously but it's
actually a quite pretty good description
you know we have meetings to set up task
forces to hold meetings to have a motion
to have a task force that will
brainstorm right that's to decide
whether we should have more coffee in
the mailroom yeah that's the pace at
which on the mailroom so so so you can't
have an institution that is supposed to
have great velocity in its ability to
adjust to I mean we teach this in the
business school yet we don't apply it it
takes us 50 years to adjust to market
conditions so regrettably I think more
and more people will look for
alternative sources of information as
you said on YouTube and everywhere else
so I got one for you that just popped
into my head that I wasn't planning on
asking you and I have no idea if you put
any thought into but one of the things
I've been thinking about lately
especially because of what's happened
here with patreon and I want to figure
out how to move ahead with my business
is that the numbers related to what's
happening online and on television seem
incredibly out of whack in that there
are millions and millions of people
ingesting all of this online content
watching for extremely long times so the
example I'll use is my chat with Shapiro
and Peterson from two weeks so it has
over a million views the watch time is
average watch time is over 40 minutes
which is unheard of on YouTube this is
way more than NBC Nightly News gets
let's say on an average night or
certainly more than CNN gets out CNN is
a better example so you take an Anderson
Cooper 8 o'clock whatever he's getting
whatever numbers he's getting that
brings in millions of dollars of revenue
a two-hour conversation that we do here
I think it's made about 5,000 bucks or
something like that
what's the behavioral or marketing
aspect of this thing that needs to be
flipped
what what's causing so that the
monetization of these conversations is
more lucrative yeah and I don't even
mean this within the lens of so that we
so that we make more money yeah I don't
even mean it that way I mean it like
something seems wrong with me with the
structures right now that people are
paying that old-school companies are
paying a ton of money for things that
have just existed forever that nobody
watches and nobody cares about then
there's this new thing
that everyone's watching younger people
really care about and yet it's getting
pennies on the dollar of the other thing
what what's the the behavior pattern for
the people that are making that above
all the levers so you're right that I
haven't thought about it so I'm doing it
on the fly yeah and maybe the best way
that I'll describe it is by telling
another story what's going to be common
about my story in what you asked is the
fact that most people once they are
anchored in a particular way of behavior
it's very difficult the inertia is very
difficult to shift so I I was invited to
speak at Stanford University Business
School I mean it doesn't get more
prestigious than this okay
the gentleman who took me out to dinner
the night before my talk at Stanford
Business School is a pretty well-known
consumer psychologist who's now one of
the editors of one of the major journals
so he's a serious academic and at one
point he says you know I didn't know you
were such a celebrity and you appear on
Joe Rogan and all this oh yeah you know
yeah I try to do it all he said and so
he look he says yeah well you know at
Stanford we don't really promote you
know this kind of stuff I said what what
do you mean and he picked sort of the
wrong guy to act this way he goes well
you know we don't do research so that we
can be have sexy findings that we can
repeat on Joe Rogan that we can you know
discuss on Joe Rogan I said well I'm not
suggesting that you either do scientific
research or appear on Joe Rogan I'm
saying do scientific research and appear
on Joe Rogan surely you as a professor
of marketing you would appreciate the
fact that appearing on Joe Rogan and
having 10 million people consume your
ideas might be as valuable as a paper
that you publish in a scientific journal
that's read this is maybe why I'm not
the I don't get invited in some of these
parties that's read by you the editor to
reviewers and your mom yeah that didn't
that didn't sit too well I mean it was a
bit frosty but but but he didn't pay for
this day but he did
he was hospitable in that not says but
that speaks to the point that you which
is
even a place like Stanford Business
School which is supposed to have the
brightest minds possible is resistant to
check I mean Joel you don't think well
you'd think that it would understand as
a business school that having your ideas
heard on a platform that is 10 million
people
yeah Rogan is a you know it's insane how
huge he is
that might have something to do with
that might be good for business perhaps
selling a book or sharing exactly or
exactly but I think so now not to get to
psychoanalytical but I will look it's an
ego defensive strategy right so I'm
speaking as him now yeah I have mastered
the set of skills that I need to succeed
in publishing papers and peer-reviewed
journals I don't think I could appear in
front of Joe Rogan and 10 million people
therefore I will denigrate those who do
it so it's a classic ego defensive
strategy whereas the truly
intellectually secure person would say
no I am going to find all of the
possible mediums where I can share my
ideas academics are in the business of
creating mimetic knowledge and spreading
it right so I create the knowledge in my
scientific research but if they Rubin
asked me to come on a show I would be a
lunatic to think to turn it down why
would I turn it down I want to promote
my ideas is that the fun part of what's
going on right now that everything is
kind of upside down so while it does
seem scary it's also like oh if you have
your head on right and you're and you're
willing to suck up your ego a little bit
and maybe do some things that maybe you
wouldn't have done 10 years ago it's
like wow there's a there's a ton of
opportunity it's unbelievably fun I wake
up every day like a kid in a candy store
I'm excited by all of the endless
possibilities that await me and I love
everything I love doing very very
hardcore scientific research
I love appearing on Ruben or Rogan I
love speaking in front of students in
class anything that allows me to spread
ideas I'm going to sign up for and I
only wish I could convince a lot of my
academic colleagues who remain quite
highfalutin in their ivory towers to
join I think they will eventually yeah
well that's actually a perfect segue can
you mention a couple of the other
academics that you've had on your
youtube channel lately
or in some hot water they dare speak the
truth yes thank you I'm going to be
plugging them now many people this what
so I had so I don't know if you know
that well you do know that I'm quite
satirical and quite sarcastic so and one
of the your video hiding underneath
that's it so now I have a series where I
hide under the table because I'm so
afraid yeah so the last installment of
that series was because I was very very
afraid because a white supremacist in
quotes
Rachel Fulton Brown who is a professor
of medieval history at the University of
Chicago was coming on my show and you
know as a brown middle-eastern person I
was very afraid of her white supremacy
now what is it that caused her to
receive the appellation of white
supremacy it's that she wrote a very
very short blog post where she said you
know three hails two white men a lot of
the freedoms that we have in the West a
lot of the the feminist virtues have
been pushed and supported and defended
by white men so maybe they deserve some
credit
my god what a Nazi I mean it's it's
almost she's almost indistinguishable
from Himmler himself so that's one case
yeah how many people came to her defense
very few yeah okay the second one is a
gentleman I just had last week on his
name is Alessandro strim Mia he is an
Italian physicist at the University of
Pisa who is also associated with the
research centre called CERN Cerf which
is an acronym in Geneva exactly so he's
there gonna blow up the universe they
gonna blow up the universe exactly and
so he was invited to speak at a gender
in theoretical physics or some some some
identity politics you know event you
know basically to support the narrative
that women are deeply discriminated
against in physics and so rather than
buy into the narrative what he decided
to do is actually present bibliometric
data do you know what that is help me
out here
bibliometric data is if you like it's
the scientific study of science
for example if you want to study which
field sites which other field you could
look at citation patterns so it's like
building networks but a scientific
network so it's you're quantifying
you're taking a snapshot of science
itself that science of science it's the
science of Sciences it's and it's called
bibliometrics they're probably the most
famous journal within that john is
called scienter metrics and i've
published a few papers in that journal
so what he did is he did a bibliometric
analysis so let me give you an example
that's so that we can give you a
concrete thing so if you have men and
women applying for a particular job in
physics what is the average number of
citations so citations for your viewers
you don't know if for example I've
published 50 scientific papers and
you've published 50 scientific papers
your 50 papers might have been cited
10,000 times my 50 papers might have
been cited 2,000 times even though we've
both published the same amount your
papers have been cited a lot more than
mine
you're more influential in that sense so
it's one measure of scientific
prominence and so what he did is he
looked at four specific jobs what is the
average number of citations that women
candidates who got the job had versus
men and he found that men had a lot more
citations right well that's just data
right beak now because he presented data
that seemed to contradict the narrative
and he did one other thing that some
would argue is a faux pas I'm not sure
how much of a full pile is he actually
compared his citation record to to other
women and named them but that data is
publicly available you know that people
thought of it as gauche but originally
when that might have been gauche or in
poor taste but that doesn't deny the
science exactly okay so these Complete
Idiot's particles for justice that what
an obnoxious name particles for justice
right that's actually the name that's
actually the name so which is a
constellation of castrated scientists
yeah about 1,600 them so if I didn't
have enough enemies now I have 1,600 new
enemies yeah give me five more minutes
let's let's go exactly they came up with
a letter an open letter you know saying
how bad he is we do not support any
physicist who dehumanizes someone based
on their religion their ethnicity their
gender orientation their race he did no
such thing
he didn't mention race he didn't mention
gender orientation he didn't mention
ethnicity or religion but somehow he's
now a Nazi on all fronts simply because
he shared the biometric data well nobody
would touch the sky guess who who would
touch him this guy and for better or
worse I've become the central repository
of every academic every student every
administrator every staff who is
aggrieved we'll end up writing to me and
frankly it's on the one hand is very
exciting because you feel like you're
helping on the other hand it's it takes
a tremendous emotional toll on you
because you have to go about your
business being a professor writing your
grants and writing your papers and
supervising your doctoral students but
every day you're overcome by ten stories
each of which upsets you but you can't
address each one so it takes a burden on
you well not that you want to be more
overwhelmed than you are but I could
probably send you usually probably four
or five hundred stories exactly like
this people who want to come on my show
and I obviously I've had some of these
people as they've sort of bubbled up you
know I've had more of the high profile
ones like a James d'amour let's say or
what happened to Brett Weinstein but but
Lindsey Shepherd from Canada
you know we helped put her on the map I
think but the amount I get these stories
from everybody I'm talking about I'm
getting them from elementary school
teachers I'm getting them from obviously
from from professors but I'm getting
them from from people that have nothing
to do with academia I'm getting them
from you know people that are in
engineering and all sorts of other
things so it's just endless but what
okay what do you think these what were
they equality and equity and diversity
oh particles for justice yeah particles
for justice so let's let's try to steal
man their argument man what do you think
they actually want do they actually want
that physics departments should have the
exact breakdown of FEMA so let's say
females are like fifty two percent of
males or forty eight something like that
so they think that actually the best way
to move physics forward in the future
yep
is to have 52 percent females 48 percent
males regardless of that men and women
like different things and the studies
are slightly differently another thing
they truly believe that let's all give
the devil is you here like or they don't
believe it in the deep recesses of their
minds when they're about to go to bed
and the privacy of their thoughts but to
the public they certainly must
demonstrate that they do believe it so
whether they truly believe it or not is
up for debate but they're certainly
signalling that they believe ok so let's
take that section of them and I that's
probably a huge amount of them right
right that's just the hot that's just
sort of the weak hostages yeah say so
let's move those people I now let's take
the true believers in this you think
they just they truly believe even though
they're educated yeah these are
physicists yes they believe that that
would produce or are they putting
physics aside for the purposes of equity
you know yeah well it's funny because I
actually what do they think is more
important equity or physics I guess is
my question equity which speaks to
another point that I talk about in my
forthcoming book yeah which is it you
know there are often times mission
statements that don't go hand and hand
if you if you do more of one you have to
give up on the other universities exist
for the pursuit of truth if in the
pursuit of truth feelings are hurt so be
it
this is exactly when sam harris on his
podcast when i appeared a few years ago
you know one of the first things that he
led with was in your scientific work god
is there anything that you consider to
be forbidden knowledge and my answer was
an unequivocal no if you are an adherent
truthfully and honestly to the
scientific method then it's not my job
as a scientist to worry about how that
knowledge might be the misused because
then it truly is a slippery slope right
we shouldn't have done physics research
because you know hiroshima and nagasaki
right that's by the way what caused one
of the reasons that caused the
application of biology from the study of
human behavior was precisely because
some social scientists thought that by
biology human nature
that could be misused like bye-bye you
do you Genesis by the Nazis by British
class elitist and therefore let's create
a new edifice that's completely removed
from reality but we're biology is no
longer relevant so what these physicists
are doing is they've been parasitized by
idiotic ideas physicists could be just
as moronic as anybody else as a matter
of fact I've met quite a few physicists
short of whatever they know in physics
they're fully lobotomized so it's not as
though being in physics affords you you
know greater knowledge and in greater
life right I guess that's just
depressing at some level or something
but isn't the other inherent problem
with that if you're afraid to go where
science will lead you because of
whatever the politically correct notion
of the day is that you're gonna leave
scientists to a lot of us you relieve
science to a lot of bad people
absolutely I mean I mean that's it
that's exactly why I get so frustrated
right I mean I've had reviewers if I've
kept the reviews I send the paper to a
journal if I show you some of the
reviews I get back you would think
although this is God being satirical
right
why is he studying sex differences does
he not know the danger of I mean do I
really in the 21st century have to
explain to you that there is inherent
value and studying evolved sex
differences the fact that you get a
reaction of indignation and disgust and
you call yourself a scientist is is like
being in the thirteenth century it's
it's breathtaking but that's because
they believe they place on sort of the
hierarchy of ideals they place hurt
feelings or the the refusal to have hurt
feelings above truth do you think all of
this like almost everything we're
talking about here and sort of
everything that we're all fighting yes
all the time
simply if we were to just boil it down
to it's like you know it's got a first
principle sort of thing that it's just
because of an abdication of personal
responsibility that people are just sort
of afraid of their shadow they're just
afraid that it's a little bit of a scary
idea to just get up every morning and go
I got to do a little better today I mean
definitely there's a bit of that but I I
think that what unites a lot of these
what in the book I call idea pathogens
right the book is
parasitic ideas that infest our brains
causing us to behave maladaptive Lee a
lot of these ideas are ultimately
abdication of reality because they make
me feel good in some way so for example
the tabula rasa premise that the empty
empty mind Perugino
you don't talk about this is basically
idea that we are born with empty minds
and it's only socialization is sort of
the blank slate the black slave exactly
so they're the fancy term is tabula rasa
okay in Latin the empty slate okay well
I thought we were doing the show in
English yeah I could break it up for you
in Arabic and Hebrew in French but
anyways but hey by the way Obama says
Pakistan in this way so he's the worldly
guy right but but the tabula rasa
premise really comes from a very hopeful
place why because it says that we are
all born with equipotential tea had I
simply been hugged better by my mother I
too could have been Michael Jordan but
there was something right there was
something in my environmental trajectory
that caused that that realization
happened for Michael Jordan but not me
there but there was nothing inherent at
the start at T equals zero that would
have led Michael Jordan to have greater
likelihood of becoming the NBA started
he would have become rather than me at
five foot six and a half right
well that's hopeful I'd like to believe
that I'd like to believe that we are all
born with zero biological no innate
differences in intelligence for example
no that makes me but you or it would
sort of be a beautiful thing it's a
networking right work so I think a lot
of these parasitic ideas all stem from a
very noble place it stems from a place
where you try to sanitize the ugliness
of reality so for example to link it
back to marketing the Dove campaign
that's probably the most successful
campaign of their Jean is one that
basically says look we're all equally
beautiful there is no beauty is a social
construct well if I'm a woman do I want
to hear that message or do I want to
hear God's ad telling me that no across
all cultures facially symmetric people
are judged as more
and facially asymmetric uber just is if
my nose was all the way this way and I
had one eye over here I wouldn't be as
attractive but if that were true that
would smell of fatalism that means I
can't I'm doomed to that asymmetry but
if you tell me no don't worry about it
in the right context people will judge
your sagging breasts your your wrinkled
face your asymmetry to be as beautiful
look there's the movement fat acceptance
for example right fat acceptance sorry
no no go ahead this is just a doozy of
one because now you have people that
that are in it is not healthy to be fat
it's not a controversial have we noticed
that I've lost there well thank you for
notice yes no but since this will work
well for you in your career and life
that love but fat acceptance yeah
basically says look it's a conspiracy
from the medical establishment to argue
that being overweight is a bad thing and
so I actually troll my physician I
joined it hey don't you dare tell me
that I need to lose weight that as a
matter of fact at one point I had gone
to see him and I actually mentioned this
in the book and he pulls out he doesn't
bring up my cholesterol scores he pulls
out a couple of tweets of mine I'm
guessing he follows me doesn't realize
that I'm being sarcastic as I write you
know my my my my physician is a complete
fattest he said that I needed to lose
weight doesn't he know that you know
this is a social construct I'm trans
gravity blah blah whatever might usually
God stuff and then he points to them and
actually my wife was in the room with me
and and he points to them and basically
he's questioning my emotional state and
my sanity so I won't say his name I go
doc I was being sarcastic hilarious so
the physicians can be parasitized by an
inability to think and detect sarcasm
yeah but but so I think there is the the
root of that though is again it's
personal responsibility right because
isn't it it's very easy to be like all
right well I'm fat or whatever it right
Anna and I have no reason
- it's not about me to get myself in
order it's not about any of that so that
it just strikes me that almost every
problem that we're seeing in society
right is due to the ultimate abdication
of people of just that it's their life
they seem to I forgot that it's their
life or something but by the way though
the fact that something is determined by
some evolutionary mechanism doesn't mean
that it is biologically deterministic I
had of course I won't mention the name
of the person I had it yeah I received
probably like you do a million emails of
people asking me for advice and I
unfortunately can't answer everybody but
once in a while someone forwarded to you
there you go that's why I received so
many yeah and so one gentleman wrote to
me who was a guy of a certain age in his
late 20s saying basically that he he had
never had sex and he feels very
distraught by than is there any hope for
me doctor sad blah blah and you know I
didn't know exactly what to answer by I
said look the reality is that many of
the attributes that women look for in
men are actually attributes that we
could improve on so for example your
economic status your social status your
educational level your confidence level
those are not determinist what is what
is determined is the fact that women are
attracted to those traits but you could
score here on them now and through hard
work through personal responsibility you
could move here now my facial symmetry I
can't change and so in that sense this
is true so yeah you're right but but
there are many attributes even though we
know the evolutionary roots of those
attributes it doesn't mean that we are
doomed it simply actually informs us
about those things that if we take
personal responsibility we could improve
on I wanted to talk to you about I asked
you right before because I didn't want
to screw it up the indeed indigenisation
in digitization at the university
universities right again i get one word
that I can't quite know so one of the
things that's happening Canada as you
know you know there's there's been a lot
of historical friction between the
Canadian government and that the native
people indigenous people yeah and so now
we've gone on hyper drive where
everything is getting indigenized so for
example when you start any ceremony at
the University you have to sell
flagellate I'm evil we are standing on
stolen line and so on which that itself
I find quite grotesque because not to
imply that there haven't been historical
grievances that should be addressed that
so on but here are students who have
nothing to do with those historical
grievances this is their moment to shine
this is their moment to be celebrated we
start off by saying you're bad you're on
stolen land admit that buy so that's one
example but that that's ok symbolic fine
but not just symbolic right because
doesn't that just leak into everything
else you're right fair enough you're
absolutely right now so here's what
bothers me more as someone who is a
dogged defender of truth
we now have what's called indigenous way
of knowing ok so here's here's the
here's where it's it's appropriate to
talk about indigenous knowledge versus
inappropriate indigenous people have
lived in certain environments that makes
them more privy to the local knowledge
of the flora of the fauna right it's
content specific knowledge if you've
lived in a particular region for 10,000
years
you might have some statistical
regularities that you've noticed as part
of your cultural transmission that the
guy who's sitting at Harvard may not
have been exposed to you have a lot of
transmitted data you accept this issue I
accept this as true and and we should
turn to to the indigenous folks for
their locally specified knowledge on the
other hand if you say no but you know I
could look at the shadow of my ancestor
whatever some booga-booga stuff because
that's an alternate way of also knowing
it's not just the white man's sexist
racist colonial science that we should
abide by no there is no extremely
good-looking Lebanese Jew way of knowing
there is no indigenous way of knowing
there is just the scientific method so
once you try to argue that there are
multiple ways of knowing epistemological
E you're entering into B s lon and I
won't put up with it can you explain to
me a way that they would say
how would they make a counter-argument
to that what would they be talking about
well what would be an indigenous way of
knowing not I'm not talking about the
legitimate part well not everything is
material science not everything is
materialism not everything can be
captured by conducting an experiment
using white man science hashtag science
must fall right
you have to decolonize your mind man you
have to accept that there are you know
Central African Way of knowing where you
understand the rain to be that God is
crying
you have to end something so you have to
incorporate people's mythologies and
full chords into ways of knowing
shamanism is a way of knowing that is
very different in terms of how you cure
cancer that has nothing to do with
Western science its BS yeah there is
only one way of knowing and it's called
the scientific method but by the way
people who do for example touch therapy
touch therapy is I have an energy state
and my and I could cure your pancreatic
cancer simply by hovering right now when
you actually do a study to check the
efficacy it obviously fails what do you
think they rebut well by putting us
through the vulgar tests of science it's
that magic there you go so there is no
indigenous way of knowing there is very
valuable indigenous knowledge that
should be maintained preserved and
shared but there is no different Epis
Tamala G there is no way to get at the
truth
other than the scientific method it's
the only game in town how is this
leaking into academia I mean is this now
is this a discipline it's just sort of
the lower layer of it everywhere that
you you you in curricula it gets
imported imported the I think it was the
Environment Minister of Quebec who
questioned when talking about some
environmental policy he basically said
something similar to what I'm saying
here where he's saying there is only the
scientific method he was clobbered no
there isn't just a scientific matter
what kind of racist big are you is there
something unique or something bizarre
about what's happening in Canada right
now that so many of the fighters right
now that
the world is looking at are coming from
Canada I think there's something in the
water
yeah well Peterson obviously I think is
the is the pinnacle of this but you but
Lindsey Shepherd I there's a series of
other people
Janice Mingo Janice a mango had in here
who's just off the charts phenomenal
that there's something happening in
Canada perhaps you guys had it pretty
good and stayed out of world affairs
enough for something but now the
internet has like made us all feel the
same right earth I don't I don't think
there's anything you I think it's just a
statistical anomaly that a few of the
forefront people happen to be from
Canada I don't think there's a it maybe
it's this is completely I'm sure Maya
I'm not sure but maybe the fact that we
are actually getting parasitized by some
of these idiotic ideas so much more
quickly so I think yeah so maybe that's
it because I think there's some
connection to Trudeau yeah so slick and
says all the right things but everyone
knows he's not doing the right things
and you know when we were in Western
Canada there was a lot of people almost
all the questions when we do these q and
A's were about what's going on with the
oil pipeline and all that and taxes and
all these things but he looks good
anywheres nice yes and he can dance
right and so people just think it's good
so maybe it's something like that like
Canadians I think generally are a little
more it's odd correct me if I'm wrong on
this my gut feeling about Canadians is
you guys are a little more inherently
live-and-let-live say libertarian except
you have a government that gives you
your dues and a whole bunch of other
things so there's a weird dichotomy
there I mean maybe although I could tell
you that in Quebec we are one of the
last functioning deeply communist places
in the world I say this somewhat
facetiously but not quite facetiously we
really and that one of the reasons why
I've always wanted to move to the United
States is because this socialist ethos
is really great for people who don't do
much and it really punishes those who
are producers yeah and so you're
constantly getting the government who
comes at you and says hey everything you
do 50/50 right so it's not enough that I
my salary is taxed at a level that is
unimaginable that would make most of the
people viewing this show
have heart attacks it's not anything
that I try to do beyond that to make a
bit if I go give a talk if I write a
book if I'm on
Riaan the government says whatever you
do forevermore if its world income if
it's on Mars we're 50/50 partners as a
matter fact ends up being much more than
5050 because your income is about 50%
but then the 50% that's left to you they
tax you 15% on what you spend so the
amount that I'm left with I mean so how
could it be that someone who it's not
that I'm very rich it's not that I make
it but if you look at sort of that I
probably am in the top 5% I'm left with
very little at the end of the year
because you know we are a gentle sweet
society where you have free health care
well it's free health care other than
the fact that I pay 50 percent of my
income for it so if you exclude the 50
percent that I pay for it it's free so
for example why isn't that upsets people
when you tell them that something is
that's free is actually paid for that
really upsets Pina because they live in
that utopia where the blank slate
premise is the theory there we go yeah
they're idiots you got one more good one
for me before we sign up we I mean we
could do this forever and I know where
unfortunately I got some more stuff I
got to do anything else that I can tell
you well my book will be out next year I
am supposed to deliver it in October
I'm feverishly working on it there was a
bit of a snag last year where I wasn't
able to work on it as much now I'm back
full throttle I have about half the book
written and somewhat disorganized
fashion our books are gonna come out at
about the same time I know that's not
that's bad news for you because of
course I'm going to overshadow you I was
about to say that we could tour together
yeah no nope yes diplomatic I'm Middle
Eastern I have to learn from you yeah
see I try to impart a little wisdom at
the end thank you sir it's been a
pleasure as always my friend
we're okay so patreon obviously but
where else can people support so this is
the thing I just signed up on subscribe
star yeah I also they could follow me I
have a YouTube channel the sad truth
yeah act God sad is my Twitter handle
I'll go out I was just going how can
they support support me from support
PayPal subscribe star and patreon yeah I
don't really don't end the show with the
with the pimping out of that nature but
I just think people are trying to figure
it out now there
they want to support good ideas and
strange and I should say I'm everyday
that I see your success you know there's
an old expression that says it whenever
I see my friends succeed something in me
dies which is the ugly emotion of envy
yeah I feel the opposite for you and I
truly mean that every as I see you
flourish I say I knew this guy when he
was a fetus and I love that you are this
big Herculean guy now good for you buddy
well I love that you're doing it right
alongside me so thank you there you go I
will say more nice things to each other
off camera so yes so just very quickly
I'm trying to figure out what to do with
the patreon situation if you are not
happy with what they're doing there and
I'm still trying to get more information
on everything you can go Dave Rubin calm
slash donate if you'd like to do that
and all right this is this is my last
taping in the studio for 2018 it was a
completely bananas here I did about a
hundred stops on the road got back into
stand-up I think we did some good stuff
here we do have shows coming out on
Monday I think we have imam tahiti and
then which we taped just a couple days
ago it's really wild a great interview
and then we've got Rabbi David Wolpe and
Bishop Bauer and I think that's on
Wednesday if I'm not mistaken we've got
a clip show at the end of the year and a
couple other things thank you for
watching and good night